one of the things i've talked about with
you guys over the years is
not unique to the united states but it's
particularly bad in the united states
which is when you have the degree of
connections between media figures who
are ostensibly journalists or reporters
are supposed to be people that are
sort of critically analyzing and talking
to you about what government is doing
when you have those media people
so closely tied in with friendly with
involved with whatever the very people
in government that they're supposed to
be covering you don't really get
journalism by definition or in any real
sense of the word and one of the things
that we've seen over time
uh partic over the last year since the
january six trump riots
is the degree to which right-wing media
like fox news and others are so
connected we're so connected to the
trump administration we've learned about
these text messages that were exchanged
between sean hannity and mark meadows
and others in the aftermath of the trump
riots about how best to manage it and
how this is a bad thing and trump's got
to stop talking about the stolen
election but then he would go on the air
and he would support the trump narrative
and do something totally different and
part of what goes on and i've talked
about this before because i've been in
some of these circles uh before on the
periphery
is
people don't want to lose access and
that influences a lot of how media
behaves they become
a
an acquaintance of someone in power
they start to get access to them and
next thing you're you know you're maria
bartoromo who has a direct line to trump
and nods along to any insane notion that
he mentioned so that's one piece of it
that we don't want to lose access part
the other part of it is how they're
actually in some cases is almost no
daylight between the media and the
government piece and there's now an
explosive new report with another little
chapter in that sean hannity fox news
propagandist
sent trump's former white house press
secretary kaylee mcinanni a post-riot
playbook
according to newly released texts
fox news's sean hannity reports huffpost
sent kaylee mcinanni a plan
to handle trump the day after the deadly
capital riot according to new newly
released text messages
hannity messaged makanani on january 7th
with a quote five-point approach for
conversations with trump
hannity was telling mcinanni how to
manage trump
according to a letter that the white
house that the house committee
investigating the riots released on
thursday
the first two items on hannity's plan of
action read
no more stolen election talk again this
is this is a trend hannity recognized
that the stolen election talk was not
helping trump
two yes impeachment and 25th amendment
are real and many people will quit so it
seems like hannity is telling mcinanny
say to trump you could be impeached
the 25th amendment could be used
your allies will quit if that happened
sort of like to warn trump and the
letter didn't reveal points three four
and five and mcinney responded in those
text messages love that
thank you that is the playbook i will
help reinforce
hannity told mackinani it was quote key
that quote no more crazy people were
allowed to access the then president
mcinanny responded yes 100 percent
mackinani days uh uh in the days after
the election
remember that mackinani appeared with
those crazy people sydney i'm trying to
think i believe there was one particular
press conference
and i don't know if it's the one where
rudy's face melted i don't
know it's all kind of a blur but mac and
annie appeared remember in her role as
a trump campaign staffer not as the
press secretary alongside some
combination of sydney powell
jenna ellis
and or rudy giuliani and yet
mcinanni knew and agreed that these are
crazy people around the president so
there's three four five different
important layers here one is this cozy
relationship between fox and the trump
administration wasn't serving anybody
you had people at fox and people around
trump who knew how insane this all was i
mean listen quite frankly
we now have text messages that show us
kaylee and hannity both thought
there were crazy people around trump
giving him bad ideas
the stolen election talk was a bad idea
and yet they both went out and
reinforced it showing that this was not
them behaving on principle this was them
behaving on
call it self-preservation for mackinani
call it ratings for hannity maintaining
access to trump whatever so that's one
aspect of this
and then of course number two
that
nobody is better off when you have this
journalism is not better off the
american people are not more informed
uh the people running government are not
running government in a way that is
better for the people um
everybody loses in these situations and
i know that there will be there will be
people who say well you know
chris cuomo seemed to be pretty friendly
with hillary clinton back in 2016. they
clearly know each other
yes they clearly have the clintons and
the cuomos clearly seem to know each
other but there was not this
operationally indistinguishable
uh
relationship that was going on when it
came to governance and it just doesn't
it seems like such a
lame comparison when you now see the
connections between fox and the trump
administration so here's just you know
the text message is just another example
i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this but i do want to just point out
that this nfl football player aaron
rodgers
is continuing to spread straight up
baseless coveted disinformation and the
guy is a role model to so many people
you know when i was a kid i read this
book by charles barkley former
basketball player about how
he really shouldn't be a role model he
behaves in certain ways because he knows
he is as a guy who's in sports but that
really these people should not be role
models and that had there was truth to
that in the 90s
it's so much more true today
here is aaron rodgers now on the pat
mcafee show
saying that the covet fact checks about
do vaccines work and stuff like that
they're all done by big pharma so you
can't trust any of them i will say i
don't believe that hatred and fear
and
name calling and any of this stuff is
going to get us out of this pandemic
it's going to be love and connection and
actually conversation and debate
and information sharing
and not information sharing that's fact
checked by the same individuals who are
you know running the pharmaceutical
industry he wants information shared
that is not being fact-checked that is
fascinating right oh
which is a lot of
a lot of the
you know when you when you look into
some of those connections it is
interesting to see some of the
connections between
fact checkers and boards and
this guy thinks he's absolutely
brilliant guys he thinks he's figured
out the ultimate truth and even delivers
it in this tone where it's he's not
taking pleasure but we can't have fact
checks from big pharma um the vaccine of
which there have been is it hundreds of
millions or have we gotten to a billion
doses given
the vaccines have been studied
in randomized controlled trials
in all sorts of different countries by
people not associated with big pharma in
the journals they disclose their
conflicts of interest
studies on do masks work they've been
randomized control you know etc etc and
this guy was almost the permanent
jeopardy host and he's going around
spreading the stuff as a reminder here
is the same guy aaron rodgers
admitting he took medical advice from
joe rogan when he got covered and um
even pat mcafee couldn't could couldn't
contain his laughter when that was
mentioned i consulted with
a now good friend of mine joe rogan
right
after he got covered
and i've been doing
a lot of the stuff that he recommended
yeah in his podcasts
and you know on the phone to me
and
i'm going to have the best immunity
possible now
so that's uh that was that um also uh
more recently
he said aaron rodgers said that there
were people watching the green bay
packers and rooting against the green
bay packers only because of his
vaccination status which actually may be
true but they're not nor they're not
like the normal football fans there
there's no doubt that there are people
who had no clue who aaron rodgers was
they found out he was saying very
strange things about covet and they were
rooting for him to lose that's not wrong
i think he's right about that because
there were a ton of people
tuning in rooting against us for one
reason and one reason only it's because
of
uh you know my vaccination status
and them wanting to see us lose so they
could pile on and uh
and enjoy and revel in the fact that uh
you know my vaccination status
was uh
you know some sort of reason why
we haven't had success in the playoffs
or whatever it might be some sort of
correlation yeah now i didn't hear that
once so so it's you know there's always
this self-importance to these guys even
just the way that he talks there's this
air of self-importance it's true that
there are some people who
wanted to see aaron rodgers lose because
they think he's a prick
i mean that that's the long and short of
it i have not heard anyone say that the
reason the green bay packers didn't do
better
is because he's unvaccinated just
doesn't it doesn't make any sense i've
not heard anyone say that it doesn't
really pass the sniff test that anybody
would say that and the the really tragic
thing here is
you know we laugh when aaron rodgers
says well the advice i got is from joe
rogan
and even pat mcafee who seems to go with
a lot of the things roger says is like
oh god
um we laugh at that but
there's so many people that don't listen
to doctors and they don't listen to
epidemiologists and they don't listen to
public health officials they listen to
joe rogan and if aaron rodgers wants to
start giving advice about covid
treatment
they'll listen to aaron rodgers as well
and that's the real tragedy of what it
is that is going on here
let me know your thoughts were you
rooting for aaron rodgers to lose
because of his vaccine status you can
let me know on twitter where you can
find me at d pacman and you can also
find me on instagram at
david.pacman we have a great friday show
for you today we will be on the ground
at the trump rally in conroe texas
tomorrow hope you'll be following that
live stream stay with us quick break and
right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount join
pacman.com
remember that the david pakman show does
depend on the support of viewers and
listeners who get memberships that at
joinpackman.com it is a direct method of
support it's not you get a hundred
dollar cable bill
and four bucks goes to fox news and it
no no you just you sign up at
joinpacman.com and you're saying this is
the one show i am supporting here and
you can use the coupon code wow 22
wow 22
to get a large discount off of your
membership
let's hear from some people in the
audience we now use discord to hear from
people you can go to davidpakman.com
discord
to find the discord and we're going to
speak to people let's go first to
michael in philly michael you are on the
air what's on your mind today
uh can you hear me well yes i can
uh thanks thanks for picking me david um
i was wondering
could a lot of people think that
it's a really really bad idea at this
point in time considering how widespread
the omicron variant is
that's my that's that's what my question
concerns
uh do you think that here in the united
states because of how mutations can
sometimes be worse than people expect
omicron being an example
do you think that
mandates of any kind
are a bad idea
are you
when you say vac when you save mandates
of any kind are you saying vaccine
mandates or other mandates so uh i mean
then i mean i mean mandates of any kind
math mandates vaccine mandates uh
uh gathering mandates mandates of any
time
right now or at any point
right now
i'm uh i think that for the next month
there still should be some restrictions
but i agree with people like vincent
racaniello
that we are getting close to close to
the point at which
it's going to start making sense to ease
up on a lot of these different things i
think businesses requiring people to be
vaccinated it's up to the business it's
completely legal and i think it's fine
but i do think that
as we move in the direction of
endemicity and it's completely
impossible to avoid exposure at this
point exposure remember not infection
we're certainly we appear to be moving
in the direction where it's going to
start to make sense to ease up off a lot
of that stuff
now that could change
that could change
all right i appreciate the call thank
you a lot going on there background
noise and uh other other noises and sort
of different things so we're gonna
move on for the time being and i do
appreciate the call let's go next to
oh i don't know why don't we go to frank
from jersey frank you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
hey how are you doing today good and
please please please turn off discord
notifications because we're every time
that bling's it's coming through
i'm sorry i have the uh i have do not
disturb on so i'm not sure why is there
something else that i should have said
on yeah in your settings notifications
just turn all of those damn
notifications off settings notifications
and then we'll stop uh hearing that and
it'll be beautiful
okay how's that
all right let's what was on your mind
today i don't know if it worked but
let's see no it did not work
give me your question and we'll take the
answer offline
okay i'm sorry so um basically uh i'll
just start with the the first one uh
right now i'm having a little bit of a
family issue where
um
my parents were originally very you know
logical with their decisions regarding
kovid and being safe and you know
actually wearing their mask and
everything
um but now unfortunately it's kind of
gotten to a point where
i mean uh you know he even showed up
yesterday with like a cloth mask and it
was just something from like the
doctor's office with like an insurance
name on it
and uh you know this is somebody who
does understand n95 and things like that
they're not vaccinated um
they just keep kind of getting more and
more crazy conspiracies off the internet
i'm kind of finding it hard to uh you
know even using some of your advice in
earlier streams that i've watched of
yours to combat conspiracy theorists
finding it really really hard to talk to
them um
with a lot of the kind of like you keep
putting it lately very very weaponized
information um what's a conspiracy
theory well give me give me what's a
conspiracy theory that they believe
right now
i mean uh i'm almost embarrassed to say
them to be honest but like
uh just given ideas like recently new
year's i really wanted to see them and
uh instead he was telling me that
because me and the woman i live with is
vaccinated the vaccine is going to
spread covet to them and uh we're the
ones that is actually going to cause it
through the spike proteins and like 8000
other you know yeah
that's one of the craziest ones that's
like the woman who said she was
experiencing rectal bleeding when she
went near vaccinated people i mean that
i don't that's that's a pretty deep hole
you got to dig your way out of you know
i don't know and if the and you're
saying that the casual socratic method
of questioning doesn't work with them
i have tried almost every logical
type of like you know reasoning even
even for example they're slightly
religious i'm not into it but you know
they for some reason believe that this
is something that is like an opinion
thing and not fact or science based yeah
and uh that's what i think is
i can't crack this wall and uh
unfortunately my mother just goes based
off of whatever my father finds and he's
just stuck on the internet for eight or
ten hours a day on you know rumble and
[ __ ] shoot and all this other guards oh
my god so listen it sounds like you've
tried a lot of things i think as a
last-ditch effort before considering you
know to what degree you want to continue
engaging in this stuff
would be
try to go with a very common um sort of
psychoanalytic question which is what
would it mean for you if this belief
weren't true if you were wrong about
this because sometimes if you can't
pierce with the socratic questions like
how did you come to believe this
sometimes people have a lot of emotion
and psychology and meaning tied up in
their beliefs
and it's the last ditch i don't know
that it's gonna do too much but but i
might say
what would it mean to you if it weren't
true that walking around near vaccinated
people did any of this stuff and the
vaccines actually work like what would
that mean to you and see what happens
that's my only other idea
that's actually a really interesting
perspective i appreciate that because i
know it's a hard kind of uh
thing to just throw at you but listen uh
i know i already took up a lot of time i
really appreciate all the work that you
do and uh you know you really put out a
great article every every day so thank
you very much all right thanks frank
from jersey and learn from frank guys
turn off all notifications all
notifications and try not to use speaker
uh we we can do this folks i know we can
do this
uh but we've got to all work together
all right let's go we have two callers
named tristan we have tristan in boston
and tristan in kansas let's maybe start
first with tristan in boston you are on
the air
tristan in boston you are on the air
tristan in boston last call for tristan
in boston
no such luck there let's try instead
with tristan in kansas tristan in kansas
you were on the air
hey can you hear me okay yes i can
okay well you kind of pulled a trump
there david because i'm actually in
kansas city missouri okay it's okay i i
i it all gets truncated so all i could
see was kansas
yeah yeah
so um
going to the situation in ukraine yes
there's a would you say there's a lot of
quote unquote western hysteria about
this because i'm just non-stop getting
bombarded with news articles and
and videos about it and everything but
you know people i'm friend you know
people i talk to in ukraine they're
saying it's it's it's being hysterized
or i don't know the right word for it
yeah
i understand well i think there's a
couple different things going on first
of all
a lot of the discussion around russia
ukraine
is related to russia's role in the world
as one of the three major superpowers
along with china and the us so a ton of
the discussion you know if if there's a
population that's about to be invaded
that population being ukrainians one of
the priorities should be
what's gonna happen to ukrainians what
do ukrainians want what is this so for
example
israel is helping to evacuate jews from
ukraine under the belief that if russia
were to invade it's probably not
particularly good for jews that's about
the people and what's that's being lost
significantly because the context is
putin versus biden and will china take
this as an opportunity to be aggressive
with taiwan or whatever the case may be
it makes sense because these are big
geopolitical players but i do think that
there's kind of a missing element which
is the ukrainian people that's a part of
it
the second part
is i do think that there's significant
politicization here
individuals looking to there are left
and right wingers that are increasingly
aligning with authoritarian regimes like
putin there's an opportunity to call
biden weak no matter what he does and so
there's a lot of political opportunism
as well
of course do you do you think there's
an actual possibility of world war three
like a strong possibility in your eyes
or do you think that's hyperbolic do you
think i think that's hyperbolic i think
that's hyperbolic and i know that the
there's you know
um
nato allies are increasingly sort of
preparing and putting troops at the
ready
but i i really don't think this is
something that even if russia were to
invade ukraine
i i have i would bet against this going
anywhere else into any kind of world war
scenario in the immediate five years
from now in a totally different
situation maybe but i don't i think that
that's
hyperbolic yeah it just it's really
reminded me a lot of you know i get
really annoyed when people compare putin
to hitler because
but i i will say that it does mirror
the beginnings of world war ii a lot
where hitler would annex his you know
the territories and the immediate
surroundings yeah here's the difference
though
here's the difference the world is
completely different than it was in the
world war ii era and as a result both of
different geopolitics technology and by
technology i mean both weapons and
surveillance technology
i don't think that just because there's
something about it that is similar it
means the outcome is going to be the
same these could be famous last words
but i think we have to consider the
context and the world in which this is
happening
yeah exactly that was that was my idea
but i just keep getting bombarded with
articles and fear mongering so it's been
giving me anxiety this helps a lot i
have friends in europe i talked to about
this too so it's it's good to have
different perspectives and not just be
stuck in like little bubbles but thank
you so much david my pleasure thanks for
the call very very important topic for
sure
uh wow folks the phone lines are packed
today and we're going to be speaking to
a variety of different people why don't
we go next to george in dublin george
you were on the air what's on your mind
today
hi can you uh can you hear me i can
uh okay great um so my question is
actually about ukraine as well
and it's um
given that the us and nato have viola uh
violated their promise from uh from the
90s to not expand eastwards
uh can we release and given that the us
has military bases all over the world
yes can we really say that putin is the
provocateur in this situation because it
seems to me that you know from a
structural perspective
you know uh nato has been provoking
russia for decades by expanding
eastwards i don't buy it no i don't buy
it i mean there's um at a certain point
we have to be able to say well hold on a
second we can do any kind of theorizing
and analysis we want we can we can have
the conversation you're having about
nato
but
you would you you would have to believe
that someone is sort of
forcing putin to mass troops at the
border
uh and it just seems like a tough bridge
for me to cross no i don't i don't i
don't think so that's a little bit too
far i'm fine with structural analysis
for sure but uh
no i don't that that's not striking me
as uh
as something that makes sense to me
i mean i i think i think i certainly
agree that putin is a is a dishonest
actor okay but it just it um i i don't i
don't really think any serious person
could disagree with that but it just
seems to me that
you know from the perspective of the
russian presidents you know what good is
nato's word or the us's word when they
said we're not going to expand eastwards
sure and then
14 eastern countries from countries from
the former eastern bloc get to join nato
you know but you know i think that the
counter still is if putin is massing
troops at the border with ukraine
he may be planning to invade ukraine and
it makes sense to
game out that possibility you know and i
say this as someone who doesn't want any
conflict whatsoever
yeah sure sure definitely um uh by the
way i'm sure you heard but uh justice
breyer um is about to retire so
biden may have a chance to appoint
someone the supreme court indeed so yeah
thanks for thank thanks thanks for
taking my call all right my pleasure
thank you so much for the call very much
appreciate that uh let's check in next
with ben from charleston south carolina
ben you're on the air
hey david
how's it going it's going well thanks
what's on your mind today
yeah a long time listener first time uh
first time catching the stream so thank
you um yeah so i have two things so one
you might even call it a critique of the
david pakman show please and then the
second would be a uh would be a short
question afterwards okay so
i noticed
it might have been uh yesterday or a
couple days ago
the
topic was the
march for life rally okay
and
so i noticed
that in your speaking about the march
for life rally
so i really respect the david pakman
show and what you do here because it's
one of the few
political commentary shows where i know
that you have a respect for um
critical thinking right
and
i worry that sometimes with like a few
different topics
you sort of allow yourself to have this
the kind of
categorical straw manning you might say
that some others engage in so for
instance a sort of verbatim phrase that
i heard was used was you know these
pro-life people
uh don't respect women's choice
something along those lines
and i just want to caution because i do
know people personally
because i have a graduate degree in
philosophy
that have carefully considered the moral
justifications and moral ramifications
of the issue of abortion
and have just come to the conclusion
looking at the different moral
considerations of that complex topic and
said
look you know a fetus has
the you know full status of a valuable
human human life and therefore you know
uh
is
entitled to protection by the state over
and above uh bodily autonomy so
do
do there exist lots of people in the
pro-life crowd that really just want to
go back to the 1940s and 50s where uh
women have less rights absolutely
there's no question about it but we have
to be careful not to extend that to like
everyone that holds that particular
position
okay yeah i mean there's a lot there and
i'm so what's the what's the fallacy i
fell prey to because like sure there's
people that come to be anti-abortion for
different reasons i i would grant that
but what's the critique of what i said
so the critique would be um maybe like a
hole to part or a generalization
um
so
saying like grouping everyone that has a
particular view into uh other particular
views that you see as antecedent so um
you know these pro-life people don't
respect women's choice whereas there are
actually philosophers that have
seriously considered you know the the
trade-offs between choice versus
um
versus uh
rights and what counts as a valuable
life but it sounds like but if i can
unders if i understand what you're
saying you're saying sure there are
people who are against abortion
whose interpretation of when life begins
means that it is a higher priority
to prevent abortion than to allow women
to choose right is that i mean that's
base they've they've come to a
particular conclusion where the woman's
ability or right to choose is not as
important as preserving the fetus right
i mean that it just sounds like you're
saying some people have some people are
against abortion because they don't
think that the woman has a right to
choose given the circumstances
right
so i acknowledge that i mean there's
lots of people who think that it's a
woman's right to choose yeah
well
so we have to be careful here obviously
so obviously we would say that um it's
not anyone's right to choose to
uh kill someone as an adult right i mean
this you're it's not your right to
choose when to kill someone as an adult
um so abortion is a very complex topic
in that it it
it deals with things like consciousness
personhood uh choice
there's no
one way to define when a fetus is a
person i i think that you know right 100
people would have 100 different opinions
on that
yeah it's complicated i just i just
caution against the sort of um
inflammatory language and like i said it
doesn't happen often because i really
respect the show
where you have a commitment to to
critical thinking um i just caution
sometimes with the categorical
uh speech where we're not lumping
everyone into a sort of camp especially
like just oh well you have this
conclusion well it must mean you have
these
reasons which are pernicious
okay so it was so it's the reasons
you're saying there are people who hold
the belief i mentioned
but they hold it
after thinking about it more deeply
right yeah okay all right i'm totally
open to that yeah totally open to that
okay and then the little little question
uh afterwards is so i
like i said i have a graduate degree in
philosophy and um i'm currently a
science teacher at a high school um i'm
partitioning pretty hard to
my administration to be able to teach a
critical thinking class
next year
i really do believe that critical
thinking class should be a core
class maybe even required in a high
school setting um
do you think do you agree with me and
then what what what in your view is the
best way to achieve that yes i i 100
agree and because i don't know enough
about how
local school curricula are determined i
would not be the right person to advise
on how to make it a reality i would talk
to education activists about about that
i appreciate the call i've got a lot of
people holding so i'm going to move on
we're going to take a very quick break
and then we will be right back with more
calls so if you're holding on to talk to
me don't hang up quite yet
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's go next to nick
from st louis missouri you're on the air
hi david uh
my question for you is uh so with the
2022 midterms coming up i just would
think it'd be a no-brainer for biden to
take some sort of stance on uh
decriminalizing marijuana
on like the federal level yeah uh i just
think that'd be an easy layup for
democrats to
you know make a comeback since the tail
like everyone's saying that they're
going to get slaughtered in the 2022 uh
midterm so what's your opinion on that i
completely agree this sort of came up a
little bit on the show last uh last week
i think that um it would be an easy
obvious net positive for biden to push
decriminalization
um there are a couple different
perspectives on how it could be done
could it be done by executive order
could it be done by simply directing the
deal uh to sort of make it happen there
are some who say he can't do it although
i've not found those legal arguments
compelling as a layperson but yeah i
completely agree there there are people
who would be mad at biden
decriminalizing cannabis but it would be
an obvious net positive and i think he
has very little interest in actually
trying to make it happen
do you think his reluctance to not try
to make anything happen on that front is
because of his own personal
or religious beliefs no i don't think so
i mean it's sort of like with the
student loan thing right where people
are saying why isn't he forgiving
student loan debt like i never thought
he cared about student loan debt and i
think at one point he said he would do
10 grand and people were saying 50. at
no point did i believe he really cared
about it i don't think it's religious i
don't think it's personal i think
there's just certain issues he doesn't
care about and he sort of talked about
them because he was running a campaign
and people imposed these issues on him i
just don't think he cares it's i wish i
had something deeper but i think it's
it's that simple
but i mean going to student loans but
given that his wife is a teacher yeah
you would think that that would have
some sort of impact and hit you know the
priorities i agree especially because
it's so popular um those two issues on
on the left marijuana maybe more you
know everyone but uh
i just i don't see why
no action or no even updates even
avoiding questions and uh briefings
about uh those issues i agree with you
100
and you know there's two sides on this
one is he's just being advised
incorrectly the other one would be there
are downsides you and i aren't thinking
of and that's why he's staying away from
these issues it's probably a mix of both
okay well thanks for answering my
question david all right my pleasure uh
great to hear from you
why don't we go next to really people
from all over the world today
it's quite a quite a situation let's try
attack
from denmark attack you were on the air
and for whatever reason i'm unable to
unmute
attack and i don't know why that's
really weird i should have all of the
necessary permissions
uh but i am unable i apologize attack
if a moderator can look into why i am
unable to unmute attack from denmark i
would love to go back to attack very
very strange
wow
let's try um let's try greg from detroit
wow now i can't i actually can't unmute
anyone right now
that is really weird
let me see if i can um
let's see if i can reconnect is our
system failing let's try going back to
attack from denmark ah there we go
attack from denmark you are now on the
air what's on your mind
yeah hello can you hear me i can
all right yeah so i had a question
basically around um
the fact that it seems to me that a lot
of american media
a lot of american media see so so attack
was just muted again
um i think we're having some kind of
permission issue guys so if moderators
can look into this one of two things is
happening
either someone is accidentally doing
something with the server muting
or
someone has um
gotten a permission they they shouldn't
have
so let's try once more attack sorry
you're back on the air let's see if it
will hold and moderators please look
into what's going on go ahead attack
yeah it's totally fine technical issues
happen right anyway so basically my my
my issue is it seems to me that a lot of
um especially very progressive and very
conservative american media when it
comes to foreign policy analysis seem to
fall over themselves trying to justify
the actions of other authoritarian
states so i mean you've had for instance
tucker carlson you know making his
insane positions about russia that
actually they're the good guys in the
ukraine conflict and i feel even on
progressive media you have people like
you know hassan abi for instance who
will say that the us is the aggressor in
the ukraine crisis and i'm just
wondering if it just comes from this
impulsive idea that any time the u.s
takes a position the u.s is by default a
bad actor or if it just comes from
almost a lack of knowledge on these
issues especially when it comes to
issues like ukraine where
every realistically speaking the us held
a secondary role in why ukraine even
came to the situation as in today yeah
so we have a very interesting situation
going on here in the u.s and you're
really getting to it
there are some on the right that are
increasingly defending a tor
authoritarian states
because they're authoritarian and they
like authoritarian states there are some
on the left that are increasingly
defending authoritarian states some
because they also like authoritarian
states but others because they see
opposition to those states as promoting
american imperialism and i am sometimes
criticized i will say on the show maybe
you even heard me say
uh i am against the chavez maduro regime
in venezuela because i am an
anti-authoritarian and they are
authoritarian and i give 10 reasons why
and then people will say you imperialist
yankee encouraging intervention in
venezuela and i go wait when did i say
that i didn't say that at all
um and so being against authoritarianist
uh authoritarian regimes that are
putatively left
is used as a proxy to call you an
imperialist so we're seeing it from both
sides for slightly different reasons
yeah i agree and it seems really weird
to me that you will see some people in
progressive circles you know um justify
the actions of an incredibly right-wing
almost fascistic state like russia which
has engaged in incredible oppression of
homosexual people even minorities
absolutely
and on the right it makes the very
little sense to me because at the same
time you know the very anti-muslim brite
seems to um fall over their heels to
praise putin when for instance putin has
a literal islamist dictatorship in the
southern part of russia and chechnya led
by a literal islamist who puts gay
people in concentration camps absolutely
and one of the catch phrases you have to
watch out for is
if you levy a critique on
um
china with the uyghurs
uh venezuela
russia what whatever
and then the reaction you get is the us
also does that stuff
that should be a red flag because it's
like yes
and i criticized the us for it as well
right i mean it's like i can criticize
both and be against invading russia and
still think that some of the things
they're doing are horribly authoritarian
the problem is a lot of people don't
really want to have that conversation
they just want to say you're an
imperialist
yeah i agree and in many ways it feels
weird to me because like you know being
from denmark obviously the media
perspective here is a bit different um
it seems to me that there is a general
consensus among left-wing and right-wing
media in denmark even among the more you
know socialistic and also more national
conservative elements yes russia is
indeed acting completely out of turn in
the ukraine crisis right um
and it seems to me like it almost in the
u.s has just turned into another thing
where you can attack whoever is in power
currently so if donald trump were in
power then conservatives would probably
be like oh donald trump is showing
strength against russia but talking
about sanctions and now because in power
it's just oh biden he wants to destroy
uh america by doing sanctions against
russia and destroying everything it
feels like it's just a part of this like
hyper-partisan landscape in american
politics 100
100 listen where in denmark are you
i'm in our house oh okay i i'm familiar
with that that's a beautiful beautiful
uh it's like a small city right
yeah so aarhus is actually the second
largest city in denmark but that doesn't
say a lot because uh denmark isn't
exactly a very populous country yes but
yeah i um i study here i'm actually
originally from northern germany there's
a danish minority in northern germany
that i'm from okay and so i moved to i
moved to denmark in uh 2017 to study and
i'm doing my master's degree currently
in european studies so obviously
european politics is very interesting to
me got it well listen i one of the
places i've enjoyed the most in the
world is denmark what's the name of
these like open-faced sandwiches that
are so popular
ah small bowl yes yes
uh those are delicious aren't they
yeah the funny thing is um so my mom is
actually american and she cannot
pronounce that at all yeah i'm not even
trying i don't think there's even a
possibility i could pronounce it
uh all right attack from uh from from
house denmark really appreciate the call
thanks for taking my call david all
right there we go folks and that is
going to do it for calls today we will
take more calls
and i hope to hear from you the next
time we're going to take a quick break
and be back with more
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the mailbag for
the week the mailbag continues to be
increasingly popular both for people who
have something constructive and
substantive to share
and people who have nothing of value to
share other than insults slurs and the
like
you can email info at davidpakman.com if
you have a message for us that maybe
would be interesting to discuss during
the mailbag
let's start today
with the email
you're a bully
paid for by george soros and alex soros
now i have to admit i have never heard
the name alex soros before um suggesting
that um
shows hosted by jewish people
are paid for by jewish person george
soros is
a very well established anti-semitic
trope um we have been targeted by it for
a very long time
uh i i have never been accused of being
paid by alex soros and i don't know who
that is presumably the son of george
soros i don't know
sounds interesting i wonder what he's up
to and of course you're a bully who am i
bullying would be the question i have
that is not uh also not an allegation
i have ever faced uh lance wrote in
asking about our facebook situation
saying david i watched your show about a
week ago where you talked about facebook
demonetizing your content for 90 days
over essentially reporting the news this
got my ire up and i contacted a friend
that works for facebook who looked into
it further
here is the official reply thank you for
bringing this to our attention we've
reviewed the content you reported and
found it doesn't violate community
standards we apologize for the mistake
here and have restored your content and
taken steps to ensure it doesn't happen
again
um and lance wants to know what happened
yes
i am now able to announce that thanks to
you about 10 of you actually we have a
ton of facebook employees in our
audience it turns out or friends and
family of facebook employees
thanks to uh all of you guys
we have been re-monetized re-monetized
on facebook a bunch of people wrote in
saying this is not anti-vaccine content
the david pakman show is not anti-vaxx
this is some kind of false algorithmic
thing
and we learned that indeed no real
person
flagged our account something about our
post
could have been the the thumbnail which
included alex jones could have been the
text we don't know got us demonetized
and it was uh incorrect and so a whole
bunch of you guys who work at facebook
submitted internal appeals it took about
15 days or so
16 days something like that
but we are remonetized on facebook and i
have only you guys to thank so i really
appreciate that let's continue with the
mailbag mike rhoden
and is not pleased with me mike says
david i noticed that on the january 19th
show you mentioned how to get at home
coveted tests would be in the bonus show
i'm sure you didn't intend this but
putting that content behind a paywall
could be viewed as tacky or underhanded
way of encouraging subscriptions the
information is not secret it's it's why
it's just covatest.gov
every day this one is frustrating every
day i just tell people what's on the
bonus show and so that day it was like
we're going to talk about the new
program to get free covet tests we're
going to talk about this we're going to
talk about that
you can just google free kova tests it's
the first thing that comes up
the information is not secret in any way
i was not encouraging subscriptions with
the idea that i would tell you where to
get free covent tests if you get a
membership
um
a little frustrating because i mean it's
a biden plan it was all over the news
it's kobetests.gov
but okay it is what it is
bill wrote in about the january 6th
committee
and says hi david sir
is there there is one thing that i would
that would greatly impact voters and
voting in 2022 or 2024. if the committee
shows somehow
that trump had nothing to do with what
happened on january 6th i know it's
unlikely but stranger things have
happened think 2016. that's a really
good point so what it what is this about
last week
i said
i want the uh january 6 committee to
finish its work before the november
elections why if republicans win in
november
as soon as they're sworn in in january
they're ending the committee
so i would like the committee to
actually finish its work
without being forcibly shut down even
though i know that no matter what the
committee says the committee could say
trump was the one guy who planned the
insurrection or whatever and it would
not change the minds of voters in other
words i don't think the results of that
committee will make a difference bill
has a good point
which is if the results were
trump is completely innocent and has no
blame whatsoever no one around trump has
any blame for the insurrection
that actually might impact 2024 and it
would be similar sort of to that last
minute james comey press conference
remember for all the talk of james comey
being so uh um hostile to trump and
friendly to hillary james comey choosing
to do that second press conference about
the hillary email investigation
so close to the 2016 election
absolutely played a role to some degree
we can't say it was a decisive role but
it played a role in the ultimate outcome
so i don't think that's going to happen
bill i agree with you but if it did if
the if the results were we finished our
investigation and trump did nothing
wrong and neither did anybody around him
that actually would be a factor i don't
expect that that's going to happen
uh haley wrote in about carhartt this i
like this story
uh conservatives on car hearts news
revealing their vaccine mandate are big
mad and making my night we definitely
should be supporting their business just
the most recent facebook post on their
page has the right acting like
snowflakes i love the story so
a lot of people i i think don't know
about the brand carhartt now i'm going
to try to accurately describe it
carhartt is a brand that sells a lot of
sort of like working gear particularly
for the cold or at least growing up in
massachusetts i would always see people
on construction site would have carhartt
pants
fleece-lined carhartt jackets and there
was this association with carhartt as
being a conservative brand rightly or
wrongly
and it may have been because it became
popular
with um uh sort of
folks who um
see it as
emblematic of rugged individualism and
being out doing
work uh you know
chainsaws and whatever anyway you guys
get the point and growing up
there was always like nearby i went to
like the
regular high school and there was an
alternative vocational high school and
the vocational high school was
significantly more conservative in its
makeup and there were a lot of carhartt
stuff around so i think there's the
association of carhartt as a
conservative brand that may not even be
accurate
turns out carhartt requires their
employees to be vaccinated and it has
gone crazy with conservatives saying we
will now boycott carhartt i saw videos
of people burning carhartt clothes and
all of this different stuff i absolutely
love it
um i don't know if there is an
alternative to carhartt is ll bean
really an alternative i don't doesn't
seem like i don't know i don't know much
about carhartt as a brand
but uh i am loving the instant
triggering that we are seeing from these
people because their beloved carhartt
says hey for safety you got to be
vaccinated to work here dustin wrote in
dustin says could or would ron desantis
pardon donald trump if trump goes to
prison and desantis becomes president
could desantis pardon trump to earn the
political favor of trump supporters and
would he so there's two issues here
and one of the issues is timing and let
me explain what i mean by that desantis
would want the
support of trumpists
to become president if he runs meaning
he needs the support before being
president he could only pardon trump
once he is president so now of course he
could announce while running if you vote
for me
i will pardon trump if trump were to be
convicted of some crimes which i don't i
don't think is going to happen so
it would be a campaign promise desantis
could make he couldn't actually do it
until he were president
but i actually see
that the growing rift between trump and
desantis will keep growing trump has
been attacking desantis of late desantis
has come back and fired at trump a
little bit and saying shouldn't have
followed him so much early in the
pandemic so i i think that
the hostilities between trump and
desantis are much much more likely to
continue growing
rather than the possibility that uh
desantis says i will save the hero trump
elect me to keep him safe i just don't
see it
we don't know if trump's running in 24
we don't know if desantis is running in
24 but that's my sense on a desantis
trump pardon could he pardon him yes
would he really do it i don't know that
it really helps his strategy
amanda wrote in and amanda said hey
david i see in your videos that you've
needed to mention when information on a
video you're showing your audience are
lies and have been debunked i've noticed
you would need to pause the video after
each lie to let us in your audience know
it isn't true and to remain in
compliance with youtube would having a
disclaimer on the bottom of the screen
be sufficient enough
at the start mentioning the content
we're about to watch is information that
has been debunked and is not true play
the video stop for your normal
commentary message on the bottom says
this isn't true or something like that
i don't know i've noticed times taken
away to stay in compliance was wondering
if there's any way around that yeah i
don't think so you know my understanding
that we've gotten from youtube is you
need to actually the content needs to be
when there is a misstatement you have to
point out that it's a misstatement and i
know it gets a little clunky and we're
thinking about ways around it remember
we're also on some platforms that are
audio only so having something visually
on the bottom of the screen that says
these are lies you were listening to
wouldn't really help
but i appreciate the the sentiment and
we're going to keep working on it amanda
cami wrote in and says do democrats want
to lose
david sir i've been thinking about this
for a while now but due to them do the
democrats want to lose elections i know
the idea seems crazy but when i think
about the people who were helped by the
republican tax cuts most of the house
and senate members on both sides of the
aisle would be at the income level to
profit off of what was done
i do believe that on social issues
democrats do have strong feelings but it
seems like they are still rich people
with a lot to gain from republican
policy do they want to profit while also
being able to cast no votes they know in
the end won't matter because they're in
the minority crazy thought but maybe
there's some truth in there so there's
two things here cami you're right that
on some issues
democrats
in power seem to have the same interest
as republicans but they don't hide that
we know that there's lots of issues
where you actually just ask them their
opinion
and there's very little difference
between democrats and republicans and
we've talked about actual interest in
enforcing antitrust right i mean we
there's a bunch of different issues at
the end of the day
democrats want
democrats benefit from being in power
and the prestige that comes with it
more than saving a couple of points off
of their taxes if the top tax rate is 37
instead of 39 so while you're
mathematically correct
that many democrats
in power in the house and senate pay
slightly lower taxes thanks to the trump
tax cuts i don't think that those two
points are enough to make them say we
don't even want to be in power
uh to save those two percentage points i
think they have much more to gain by
being in positions of power that's my
instinct and of course
you know you you might disagree but
that's uh all the evidence i've seen
points in that direction
all right if you have something you want
to ask me talk to me about
inquire about criticize demand a
correction for even you can email info
davidpakman.com and maybe your email
will be featured on next week's mailbag
remember that the show doesn't have to
end now we do the bonus show every day
for our members and you can sign up at
joinpackman.com